welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Darth initial
and with the rise of Skywalker and now
out for worldwide release it seems like
fans are more split than kylo Ren was
over killing his father
we scored it at a five-hour 10:00 but
there have been some people who have
completely slammed the entire movie
including Mandalorian star
Jake Annibale who recently took to
Instagram to rant about how bad the film
was you may remember that can avail
recently portrayed a bounty under name
Toro in the Disney Plus show the
Mandalorian and it looks like the huge
Star Wars fan wasn't impressed with the
movie overall refusing to hold back jake
labeled the film as the worst Star Wars
movie ever made and described it as an
absolute effing failure the character
who went on to see on the first night of
its release stayed the following in a
big post on Instagram rise of Skywalker
was hands down the worst Star Wars movie
an absolute effing failure when to see
it last night and I woke up still mad
like it rendered the entire new trilogy
completely useless there were more
potholes and there were plot and the
amount of by the way it was absolutely
infuriating rise of Skywalker
by the way dumbass title was worse than
Phantom Menace and last year I combined
fight me cannibal was later asked if he
felt differently if he was in the film
and the actor replied with honestly I
think I'd be more mad obviously I can't
speak on behalf of the cast to some
actors this is just a job and maybe
they're just happy to be working to it
just say more power to them also maybe
they effing love the new Star Wars in
which case that's effing dope that they
got to work on something that they truly
enjoy personally I've been a huge Star
Wars fan since I was a kid and I felt
pretty let down by the overall laziness
of this new trilogy and also a bit angry
at the entitlement of it for pretty much
season control of the franchise as a
whole by basically saying now we don't
like that ending that everyone's been
cool with for decades let's change it I
personally would feel pretty depressed
if I was in the new Star Wars movie as a
main character I mean if I was a dude
wearing an alien puppet or whatever
effing stoked but still so I guess you
could say it doesn't look like he's
overly happy with the new movie
personally I do feel like there's a lot
of validity in what he's saying with the
plot holes being big enough to fly
Deathstar through it also does in my
opinion negate the ending of Return of
the Jedi by returning the big villain of
the piece and making Vader's sacrifice
completely pointless however there are a
lot of fans out there that are happy
with the film and on my ending explained
video I had many people calling it a
satisfying ending for the franchise he
also called me a decade a couple of them
and it really obviously though
everyone's entitled to their own opinion
and it looks like everyone's completely
torn on the entire thing with some
people slamming the movie while others
sleep to its defense the movie currently
sits up 57% on Rotten Tomatoes with
almost being split completely down the
middle as far as reaction goes
personally though I kind of feel like
when you're in this profession
especially as connected to Star Wars as
kind of a Liz then maybe you should keep
your opinions to yourself and whilst I
agree with what he's saying it does look
a bit unprofessional that's just me
though maybe maybe it's a good thing
that people close the project feel like
they can talk badly about it as it will
allow the franchise to grow and go in a
better direction with the inevitable
sequels that are yet definitely coming
down the line because yet Disney they
they can't come up with any original
ideas anyway obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the entire thing and if
you agree with Jake or if you enjoyed
the movie I can see this being a very
controversial post so let me know which
side you fall on if you enjoyed this
video then please force push that like
button and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the rise of Skywalker which
would be linked at the end we go over
everything that you need to know about
the movie what we liked what we disliked
and why it's causing so much controversy
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free adjoining we have
an awesome community so I hope they see
you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the air
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe to the
and leave your thoughts on the post in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
January and the settle be shipped out
from the into ever gets the prize so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe huge thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace